cuenta la leyenda que hace muchos años
hubo un estratega militar que quiso
pagarle al hombre que inventó el ajedrez
ya que este juego le permitía analizar
movimientos justo como él lo hacía con
sus ejércitos para mejorar sus tácticas
de guerra
entonces el estratega le dijo que pidió
lo que quisiera porque era muy rico el
hombre le respondió que quería granos de
arroz y sabiendo que 1000 granos son
apenas 30 gramos pareció que pedía muy
poco
pero quería un grano de arroz por la
primera casilla del tablero 2 por la
segunda 4 por la tercera 8 por la cuarta
y así hasta haber duplicado la cantidad
de granos 64 veces una por cada casilla
del tablero
al estratega le pareció poca cosa y
ordenó pagar los granos de arroz
solicitados pero su tesorero se dio
cuenta de que la cantidad de granos
rebasaba el valor que tenía toda su
riqueza ya que por cada casilla se
duplica el valor anterior
de esta manera obtenemos la cantidad de
18 trillones y medio aproximadamente
entonces el estratega entendió que no
podría pagar por algo que el inventor
quería darle a la humanidad
si consideramos que en un año muy bueno
la cosecha de arroz de todo el mundo es
de 600 millones de toneladas la cantidad
de arroz solicitada equivale a la
cosecha mundial de arroz de novecientos
siete años algo que nunca podrían reunir
este es un ejemplo de cómo un número que
pareciera pequeño puede crecer al
multiplicarlo sucesivamente las series
de números que se comportan así se
llaman progresiones geométricas lo
primero que hay que hacer es identificar
con qué regularidad incrementa la
sucesión es decir si crece o disminuye y
cómo lo hace
veamos un ejemplo
en este caso del 3 al 6 existe una
multiplicación por 2 del 6 al 12
nuevamente es por 2 del 12 al 24 es por
2 y así notamos que todos los elementos
de la sucesión se van multiplicando por
2 por lo tanto el siguiente número será
has visto que a veces en los juegos
aparecen símbolos como estos indican un
multiplicador es decir que los puntos
que vas acumulando se van multiplicando
por el número que diga imagina que esa
multiplicación se fuera repitiendo y
repitiendo tendríamos muchos puntos muy
rápido y aumentarían como los granos de
arroz
imaginemos un videojuego donde pasa esto
y los puntos se multiplican y
multiplican por el mismo número si
empiezas con 3 puntos y tu multiplicador
es 4 cuántos puntos y días acumulando
primero tendrías tres y luego doce
porque 3 por 4 2 después ese 12 lo
multiplicamos por cuatro y tenemos 48
creo que esté multiplicador nos conviene
bastante después el 48 por 4 nos da 192
192 por cuatro son 768 que número sigue
es muy sencillo sólo tienes que volver a
multiplicar por 4
esto es lo increíble de estas sucesiones
la manera en que incrementan o
disminuyen es constante y así sabemos
que sigue el 3.072 guau 3 mil 72 puntos
y sólo empezamos con 3
ahora imagina que en ese mismo juego
cada vez que pierdes una vida tus puntos
se reducen a la mitad inicias con 2400 y
quieres saber cuántas vidas puedes
perder antes de tener menos de 100
puntos pausa el vídeo e intenta
resolverlo
tenemos 2400 puntos que disminuyen a la
mitad cada que perdemos una vida por lo
que al perder la primera vida nos
quedaríamos con 1200 puntos esto lo
obtenemos al dividir entre 2 o lo que es
lo mismo multiplicar por un medio lo que
se te haga más sencillo las progresiones
geométricas que disminuyen se obtienen
de esta manera dividiendo entre números
mayores que uno o multiplicando por
números menores que uno
con la segunda vida llegamos a 600 la
tercera nos deja con 300 parece que nos
quitan puntos muy rápido a la cuarta
vida nos quedamos con 150 puntos y para
la quinta ya solo tenemos 75 así que
podemos perder 4 vidas antes de que
estemos por debajo de los 100 puntos
este juego sería muy arriesgado haces
puntos muy rápido pero también los
pierdes rapidísimo
sigue imaginando y descubriendo más
progresiones geométricas y déjate
sorprender por las matemáticas